now out of all the nuts walnuts have
something called ala that stands for
alpha linolenic
acid which is a precursor to
epa and dha which are the omega-3 fatty
acids but ala itself has some unique
benefits
for your skin it can actually help
prevent scaly skin
dermatitis
hyperpigmentation of the skin where you
have dark blotches through the skin it's
also been known to prevent skin atrophy
and of course if it converts to the more
powerful forms of omega-3 it can help a
lot of things like your heart
inflammation brain health and the list
goes on and on and on but you have to
realize that only a percentage of ala
converts to epa and dha so to convert to
epa it's roughly about between 10 to 21
and then converting to dha we're only
getting between five to nine percent
also there's some interesting studies
that show benefits for your
cardiovascular
system yeah seven out of eight of the
studies showed benefits to the
endothelial wall of the inside of your
arteries
now realize these studies were not on a
lot of people so
you know it's a correlation but it's not
proof that it can actually help your
heart also it was shown that there was a
shift from
small particle size ldl to large
particle size ldl and walnuts have
folate uh vitamin e
polyphenols and they're low in lysine
and high in arginine now arginine can
help increase
growth hormone it can help rid excess
ammonia
so it's involved in the urea
cycle also arginine can increase nitric
oxide which is good for blood pressure
and cardiovascular health here's the
problem with walnuts most people eat
them raw and they have
phytates sometimes even more than grains
and they have enzyme inhibitors so they
can create
bloating however the solution is to
germinate the walnuts so you'd soak them
in water between 24 and 48 hours and
that will remove the phytates as well as
the enzyme inhibitors of course you're
gonna have to dry them out in the oven
under low heats or a dehydrator but the
problem with phytates is that phytates
block certain minerals like zinc
iron
magnesium so our bodies can tolerate a
certain amount of phytates but if we're
consuming too much that can create a
problem with the mineral absorption as
well as our digestion itself now as far
as the enzyme inhibitors it can inhibit
pepsin which is involved in protein
digestion in your stomach it can also
inhibit amylase which has to do with
carbohydrate carbohydrate metabolism as
well as inhibiting trypsin in your small
intestine and this is why if you eat too
many nuts you're going to feel kind of
bloated and you might have constipation
however if you germinate the nuts you'll
have much less problem now recently i've
been consuming
these right here sprouted organic
walnuts and it's a really good brand but
i consume these after a meal and they're
quite delicious and they don't create
the bloating that normal walnuts can
create but apparently they germinate
these for about 48 hours
and i'm gonna i'll put a link down below
because when i find a good quality
product that people work hard at
creating
i promote it now one little point i
would only recommend the plain not the
other ones because the other ones have i
think some honey which i don't recommend
now if you haven't seen my other video i
did on pistachios
let me put that up right here check it
out
you